i compadre from the NFL media group man
who I have known for quite some time
15 seasons in the National Football
League fourth overall pick in the 1994
draft out of USC three-time Super Bowl
champion in my fellow NFL Network good
to see you Willie McGinest
how are you I am great all right let's
uh let's jump right into this Josh
Gordon trade what do you think of it oh
I thought no no IIIi did think this when
they said they were gonna release Josh
Gordon I thought of a few teams Dallas
was one and the pages was the other one
because they of the environment and
because of their culture and the
resources they were put around this
young man the upside is we already know
what that is if he's on the field if
he's being accountable if he's handling
his business and if it doesn't work out
they've been here before you know with a
couple of players otro cinco Hainsworth
a fifth round pick so I was saying like
for the Patriots they're thin they
wouldn't make this move if they they
didn't need to they're thin this is not
something short-term this is something I
think it's gonna hurt help them long
term I don't think they need to rush him
and they'll get Edelman back soon but
after playing against the jaguars they
noticed hey we do need a little more
firepower and we can bring a guy like
this in and if we can get him to conform
to our culture or what we do here I
think it'll be extraordinaire it's Honda
inside a report here with Willie
McGinest you're the perfect guess for
this sort of thing so what happens when
josh gordon gets acquired walked me
through how they're going to initiate
him and they do your job way well first
of all I think he's gonna have a
conversation with with Bill Belichick in
the ownership and they're gonna you know
they're gonna have to be pretty raw and
uncut with him in him with them as well
and I think with craft and the Kraft
family they have resources outside of
the uniforms for him you know saud
outside of a football player because I
think it starts with his life first you
got to make sure his life is in order
and he's making the right decisions you
don't think they did their due diligence
I beg their hand that's right I
definitely think they have but it's
still up to the individuals josh has to
want it they could do everything
possible and put everything around him
all the resources and everything around
this young man but I think at the end of
the day he has to make the right
decisions and
by in a hundred percent as well well I
mean if if he does believe in a higher
power Josh Gordon right then he's got to
realize that higher power has placed an
incredible incredible change of
opportunity and potentially fortune for
him because this is it right I mean if
he goes to New England he has an
opportunity to win championships and
gain whatever he might have lost
financially reputationally
back instantly there's no question and
if he doesn't succeed here then what is
he giving as a message to the rest of
the National Football League right and I
think the the message here is if you
can't get it right there who are else
are you gonna get it right and I think
this is a great opportunity like you
mentioned rich and you know it it's
gonna take some work and I think he can
help a lot of football teams across the
league but it has to be the right
environment it has to be the right
locker room it has to be the right
support system I think the players
understand that and you know I know Rob
Nika Fitch k mounds like this what kind
of message is this to the other players
well if I was in that locker room I
would be excited and it's not a teammate
it's a family member now and that's how
we treated everything in New England as
family it wasn't just about football and
I think that's what made us so close as
a unit and I think a guy like Tom and
guys on this offense and on the other
side of the ball the the good
personalities and characters they have
in that locker room will come together
and wrapped around their hands around
this young man is sometimes rich you
need a fresh start you need to be in a
different environment Cleveland did a
great job I would say we're trying with
Josh go and it didn't work there this is
another great opportunity for him so
we'll have to wait and see what happens
but I think if he wants it it's gonna
happen and it's gonna be I'm not gonna
compare it to Randy Moss because I was
special he unique but I think he's gonna
have the same type of impact well in
terms of you know the comparison of
Randy Moss let's get into the football
aspect of this right here in the Honda
inside a rapport with Willie McGinest
and I'm I'm kind of hesitantly broaching
this
because football may turn out to be
insignificant because of all the other
aspects of Josh Gordon's life that
potentially might right prove that he's
not ready for foot away so but for the
moment let's assume that he is ready for
football and he's ready to play football
and the question is is how does it work
how does he function in a Patriots
offense knowing his game does it work I
think it works absolutely I do I think
josh mcdaniels will give him a game plan
they would create a game plan for him
for the time being he will learn certain
plays and get him and get him familiar
with the PlayBook and he has to learn
Brady they got to be on the same page he
has to learn how the adjustments work in
all those different nuances with the
playbook it changes from week to week
there that's the tough part they don't
have just one system that they throw out
there every single week so first of all
he has to learn the foundation of the
offense and they'll feed it to him slow
like I said they're not gonna rush this
this is long-term this is playoffs
this is midseason you know this is us
competing for AFC championship possibly
on the road you need to have firepower
so I would say once he learns the system
and they get him going they'll feed him
slowly and they'll just build up if I'm
thinking about this the right way
they'll build him up till he becomes
comfortable in the system and once he
gets going I think that offers to be
unstoppable just think you know you got
elderman you got Hogan you got the
running back she got Gronk you got Josh
Gordon if everybody's on the same page
that's tough that's tough to record with
and and we all know schematically they
know how to create a matchup problem for
you though but if somehow schematically
that matchup problem doesn't exist
pre-snap the goat will make sure it does
once the ball is snapped I mean it
really is a frightening concept when you
think about it football wise what about
the idea you're seeing out there that
he's not a precise enough route runner
for Brady I don't I don't I don't
believe that I've seen him take over
games I've seen him come back in six to
eight weeks in 1,400 yards and play at a
certain level I think within their
system you do have to be disciplined and
you do have to be discipline
you're out running and everything else I
think he'll he'll be that and they'll
put the pressure on him for that
and I think he wants that you know I
think he has a quarterback that he'll
come in and respect right away he'll
respect josh mcdaniels it's proven like
you mentioned over a couple of decades
of seeing this why would you go against
the grain so it's gonna take some for
him to learn it for him to play at a
certain level and make sure what he's
doing is is gonna be on the same page
but I don't think his route rating is
gonna be an issue he's closer to being
in his prime then he has towards the end
of his career if you know that's my
friend he's played 11 games since 2013
season run where he had a breakout on
field season but we also the reason why
he's played only 11 games is he admitted
he was drunk or he was not sober every
single game day right so but again let's
justwell a couple more here on the
football question with Willie McGinest
here Brady do you think he was asked
about the trade product absolutely
absolutely I think him and Belichick and
Josh are all on the same page and made
decisions he collectively he didn't just
learn about it ten minutes before
talking to your brain
I don't I don't think so I me up I think
like they do a lot of things
collectively now he's an important part
to that and I think that to exist in
that offense and on that team especially
on the offensive side of the ball Brady
has to be on board and I know Belichick
they have those type of conversations
nobody's hitting anybody with any big
surprises now why was can walk me
through this is the ultimate insider why
was Brady and McDaniels barking like
they were after some of the offensive
sets in Jacksonville family barks man I
know they bark they get into it about
what well when you're not when you're
not executing the way you want to
execute when plays are being missed when
things are not happening the way you
want it to you get you get a little
emotional it's not the first time I'm
I'm just playing what brought it about
and is that what cuz again when you saw
in Jacksonville right - part of this is
what I were it's all interconnected what
I've just brought up the result and week
to write the trade for Josh Gordon right
how does this all say each other like he
did
enough so that was a part of the Mars it
all work together that you said that
they saw what had been a check saw what
happened in week two in Jacksonville I
would you safer Meyer I will say it from
a football mind to be able to exploit a
defense like that that's the type of
defense you're gonna see in the playoffs
I mean no of course right we all expect
Jack Jackson go to beat it I I so in
order to exploit that defense and make
plays you got to have playmakers and you
got to have guys making plays they
figured out how to take Gronk out of
that game they figured out how to take
James White or limit James White in that
game that's so good defensive of Minds
do that they take away your number-one
threats and they want everybody else to
beat you so in seeing that you don't
have a edelman right he's not there
Phillip Dorsett is new to the system
he's finding his way but if you add a
Josh Gordon to that and I'm not saying
Brady was on the sideline hard being
disgruntled about give me Gordon right
I'm saying it wasn't executing right the
offense the way they needed to be and it
wasn't working so you get frustrated
we've seen that with Billy O'Brien and
Brady before you know why you say like I
need more give me Josh girl I want to
know what was not firing in that game
and how does it manifest itself in terms
of the Patriots ability to get back to
the Super Bowl well I would say when
you're not executing and you're not
making plays and things are not working
right a lot had to do with Jacksonville
okay they're that good right there
they're really that good a lot had to do
with Jacksonville I'm not taking
anything away from them they came out
and they ball they execute it they did
exactly what it they needed to do on
both sides of the ball yeah to win that
game at home and when you get down which
the Patriots knew that going in you get
down it's tough to climb your way back
out and you get frustrated I heard Brady
said what do you saying do your job
there was a lot of barking going on yeah
so things went into his head yeah things
were breaking down be smart do your job
do what you're supposed to do a lot of
things are breaking down so we all get
frustrated and do that so what's your
best guess as we wrap up this on inside
a report and
you know like you're gonna stick around
by the way for von miller you'll help me
interview them and it'll great one
that's coming up but balla lacks this
one for me bottom line what happened but
my best guess is this week too the
Patriots have lost their lost games
early in the season they will make
adjustments this edition with Josh
Gordon would definitely help if he if he
fits in all the way around like we
talked about we have no idea what's
right we have no idea outside of that
Julian Edelman be back they'll make
adjustments and this office will look
different an upcoming yeah and in terms
of Gordon I think the comparisons to
Randy Moss I mean I don't think anybody
thinks that he's gonna get a gold jacket
I'm saying Randy Moss 2.0 a lot of
people are because the talent level well
you tell me who's the most fit you tell
me Brady's most physical outside the
numbers threat not named Ron oh okay
receiver player right that he is how
outside the numbers see that was key I
got caught I'm parsing it the way yeah
outside the numbers right physical for
Tom Brady what you can't compare a lot
of people to Randy Moss and Josh Gordon
will probably be that guy far as statue
that's what I speed stripped all those
different easy target the Honda inside a
report has always brought to you by our
friends at Honda the Honda Accord where
they're headed to the stadium are just
running out for snacks the Accord gets
you there in comfort and it gets you
there in style with a sophisticated
redesign and high-tech features like
standard Honda sensing the Accord is the
most impressive Honda ever we're gonna
take a break we'll come back we'll e I
want to talk with you about Khalil Mac
Amin and what we saw last night and what
you took out of that game between the
Bears and the Seahawks the roughing the
passer penalty on Clay Matthews the NFL
doubling down saying not only was that a
proper call that they're putting it on
tape to show two teams what not to do
and what they will call and then Von
Miller will call and we'll have you part
of it all right that's Willie McGinest
here on the Rich Eisen show when we come
back
the poll question Chris Brockman get
ready to tee that up brought to you by
our friends at true car with terms like
dealer priced list price and invoice
true car shows you what other people
paid for the car you want you can
recognize a good price when you're ready
to buy newer used visit true car to
enjoy a more confident car buying
experience Chris please ask it of
three-time Super Bowl champion Willie
McGinest who's still here in studio with
us getting set to take the phone call of
Von Miller to interview him here on the
show what do you have over there Chris
alright well way which winless team is
in the most trouble winless team Giants
Raiders Seahawks Steelers Texans
traitors you didn't stutter no why
because every every week after the
interview they talked about the defense
and they can't get past rush they can't
get two running backs with all these
different things you knew that going in
and i know paul gunter was a good
addition but he's not making adjustments
and when i broke down the tape you've
got to find other creative ways you know
i'm gonna like the the the khalil mag
thing is over okay he's not coming back
so we can stop talking about that but if
you don't have a dominate guy like that
up front you got to find other ways to
create pressure and get to the
quarterback if that's what's happening
and when you're up 13-0 against the
denver broncos the game should be over
if you got a solid defense and it just
you know you give up these big leagues
you can't stop anybody you can't get to
the quarterback you got to make an
adjustment and I know sometimes
coordinators get a little stubborn in
their system but the great teams make
adjustments and find other ways and when
you look at Jon Gruden you know they're
gonna score points they got playmakers
on that side of the ball he's frustrated
and he's saying again we can't do this
so we can't do this defensively that's
the direct message to the to the
defensive coordinator you got to find
you got to do you got to change it up
and they are also 2 games behind our
guest von Miller that's calling in
shortly here on the show and also Kansas
City who looks so loaded on offense
it's absurd the charges are looking
pretty good that's true that's a very
difficult last place in that divisions
chargers and rams
coming up this weekend as well it'll be
a lot of fun here in Los Angeles what do
you think of Khalil Mack looking in that
Chicago Bears uniform line he is what he
is he is well
we all expected I mean he's a beast he
fits that mantra of that Chicago bear
right when he for our first hominid
Jersey I was like that fits him so
perfect not not that he didn't look good
in her Raiders no I didn't either for
him too but you know he's going to a
system that they were already a solid
defense before he got that era top team
and in sacks last year and when you add
him and Vic Fangio system and what he's
going to be able to do a lot of people
say well was he is he gonna be able to
make the transition he doesn't drop into
coverage he's not a line back he's the
defensive end now and I know he's made
all-pro in both positions but he's gonna
be a defensive end they're gonna use him
they got a game plan and put him in
those stunts and games and let him do
what he does and I was just about I was
excited man watching him I was just
about to say that that he wants to be a
defensive end just in case he gets
franchise technical we also know he
doesn't have to worry about that anymore
he has been paid yes the Steelers though
are an interesting choice on that poll
question war man oh one in one Brown
didn't show up for work yesterday we're
trying to find out why levy on bail what
in the world is the answer there in
Pittsburgh Willie I think for the the
bail situation it's is pretty much far
gone I think he's knows he's not gonna
be a Pittsburgh Steeler next year there
is no Dylan place they're not gonna
franchise him again it didn't work out
so now I think far as Belle's mindset in
his agents Ennis you know his his group
is preservation of body I'm gonna
preserve my body for the next team they
know once he reports that they're going
to ride him to the wheels fall off in
every aspect of the game he understands
that so the the more weeks that he's not
there it takes reps off of him in
practice it takes reps off of him in
games and I know that's probably a
selfish approach but he's like they
didn't invest in me so I'm gonna save my
talents and my body for the next team
that you know that I'm gonna be playing
for because they will invest in me so
what if the Steelers threw a few million
bucks on top of his tender he would say
no to something I don't know if they can
do that I think that they won't do that
they can basically simply will make you
the highest-paid player in the game
for this year 2018 that's great but
there's no long term the problem with
his contract and why he's not there
because they did throw a nice deal at
him but the guarantee money was not
there over the course of a number of
years so with him as a running back he's
looking at Gurley signing you know David
Johnson he knows that pretty much before
those guys sign that the number he's at
at his franchise tag is he set the
market but they've got to me in
Pittsburgh and again they don't do long
term guarantee but for me I guess it's
easy to say sitting from this chair at
the Rich Eisen checking for von miller
to call in shortly that you look at
where you're standing right now with
levy on bail there and Antonio Brown
there and Bend there well you only got
one more year of it that's it figure out
a way to get levy on bail in now figure
it out but unless what's I don't know I
I don't know what it is it's it's just
throw throw them on an amount of money
and then when people will say them why'd
you screw with them and we tried we
figured it out we want them happy we
think we can win the Super Bowl this
year have a course because our defense
isn't very good they won't say that
publicly there you go and then if the
next person comes at them and says well
you did it for bail you could say well
you're not living on bail again I know
it's easy for me to say because the way
that they're going about it right now
their defense isn't all that good they
need bail to go point for point they
need to get up 28 nothing so the defense
doesn't have to think that they're
playing downhill all the time right is
bail the problem or is the defense the
problem a defense is definitely a
problem right so they're scoring points
so what you're just gonna no no no I'm
not saying that they're scoring points
nothing James Connor let's not overlook
the fact that he's been playing
unbelievable he is but he's for split
him out y know he's different
he is different but they don't have him
so if I'm looking at the problem is it's
a bigger picture right now is it bail
not being there I think you're probably
okay let's just say it counts for ten
more points with the offense they're
still not stopping anybody making about
42 points or whatever that number is the
Kansas City it wasn't even close well
it's not just the Steelers either I mean
I'm looking at these totals through week
265 total pass
and touchdowns that in week two that was
the most in three years a hundred and
2.6 combined passer rating in week two
that's the highest in eight years we're
seeing an absurd amount of points go on
right now Kurt Warner Trent Dilfer was
on the show yesterday are saying it's
the rules that that are out there it's
not a fair fight offense and defense and
then we see what happened with Clay
Matthews this past week what D what do
you think of that call and the NFL's
decision to I don't like I don't like to
call I understand what they're trying to
do and and with any any any rule any
rule change any anything that's
incorporated into the league they're
gonna make mistakes and it's gonna take
some time to work out the kinks I would
say and I know that these referees watch
tape I know they get graded and I know
they review all these play calls this
was significant because it changed that
pretty much the outcome of the game they
did it did and when I watched this play
okay you could have probably got clay a
week ago with the call that they got
away yeah I I would say no argument for
me I think he did hit right did Drew be
the true hit untrue Biscay I think right
okay that's fine you got you got that
word right but this one this week
obviously you could tell he was
conscious when he was going down I saw
him extend the hand and I put the
shoulder in him but to actually put the
weight on the side of the quarterback
right and at the end of the day you see
a hand go right there yeah that shoulder
could have been going into the corner
left his left hand he used it to make
sure that his full body weight did not
land exactly Hortis so he was conscious
of the fact that what he was doing you
you can't just pillow lay these guys
down
you got a at you you can't take away the
football aspect of some of these plays
and I get it we're trying to protect the
quarterback position and you know
unfortunately his teammate is the one
who created this role from Anthony bar
hit on you know on Rogers last year but
the referees have got to do a better job
in this instance to maybe come together
let's huddle up after this play and make
sure we got the right call but they
didn't
the league says they got the right call
and according to again all reports this
is going to be not only I don't agree
with this one but I get with your honor
this is gonna be put on a video being
sent to all teams saying this is the way
we're going to call it and and and the
left arm that you were pointing out
about Clay Matthews that it looked like
he was doing a one-handed push-up right
like you're made sure it took the
pressure off of Kirk Cousins that arm
was visible to Tony currenty who might
have been looking at the feet watching
the feet fly up in the air and what
looked like to be potentially an
unnatural being picked up motion but
it's because Kirk Cousins was moving
forward as as Clay Matthews was hitting
him the problem for me is is the NFL
seems to be creating moments where boot
penalizing players for hitting
quarterbacks that aren't being
physically harmed by the hit right right
to me I know they don't want it to get
to the part where they get physically
harmed when they're trying to prevent
that and I get that but still a good
football play you got to let stand and
it shouldn't be penalized and I thought
in my opinion that was a good football
play I agree with you and in it what it
does is it does football wise set up the
next Vikings Packers game for being the
tiebreak because there's a time whoever
wins the week twelve game in Minnesota
might win that division you know what
else it does though rich when you look
at some of these plays you'll get
defenders that'll come in and they'll be
tentative of how they hit quarterback so
bait or break tackles and they go on and
make a great play down the field and
those defenders will get yelled at and
they'll get criticized in meetings and
they'll go back to what they normally do
it's finished in a play that's what
we're taught finish the play finish it
the right way though without trying to
do the extras the power driving at all I
definitely agree 1,000% but you get guys
being overly cautious and it'll create
plays for the offense now because guys
are thinking about that before I let you
go Willie do you want to talk USC
football we're out of time no we can I
got plenty of time well what do you
think I think we got to get it together
I think we got to get it together man
there's a lot of unhappy people in this
it is man it is and you know I've been
sentenced for the last couple of years
we got to get better in the trenches we
got to be able to win the trenches and
when you when you talk it's not just
enough to play in the Rose Bowl and in
the win games and and have a winning
record the expectations for USC is to be
in the playoffs and be competing for
national championships and you know
everybody that's there I support man I
don't want to be negative or you know
say anything but we've got to get
together we got to play at another level
when we go in and play these really good
teams we got to compete and we got to
step our game up and we got a coach
better we got to play better all the way
around all you sound like Belichick
right I'm just saying like we do I mean
we don't know but my according producer
Don Bowie was a big Trojan okay he asked
me a question in my ear twice while you
were going on your soliloquy there but I
will ask it is clay Helton the guy for
the job there he's the guy right now
he's their coach you know I'm not
involved in the decision and I try not
to be critical but without being
critical any coach in any high profile
job when you don't win and perform at a
certain level there's pressure there's
pressure I don't care who you are
there's pressure so you know I don't
know what that means like I said but I
support my Trojans I support the
coaching staff as long as everybody's
there we've got to do a better job and
the only way to fight your way out of
that and eliminate all those questions
is to win in the big game win football
games you want total access tonight no I
am NOT dumar tomorrow night on NFL
Network I felt like we were until I back
on my total axis days with you sitting
here and we interval von Miller that was
a lot of fun great to see Willie let's
do this on the regular at Willie
McGinest on Twitter to follow Willie
McGinest
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience